I got smoke too okay
we are going to begin the madness starts
now are we addressing the elephant in
the room which is what huh
I am listen I'll light up the internet
okay let me let me address it let me
address a little bit of it you get me
just pearly things yeah just pearly
things is a network yeah so when you
when you tag just pearly things just
know you're coming for everyone on the
on the show with all our views combined
yeah do you know what pearly things is
it's the girl we covered the one who
doesn't want women to be able to vote or
have birth control because like uh women
don't go to the draft this was Pearl's
World I'd get rid of birth control I'd
ban it but that'll never happen
I think that was the root of all evil
and I've actually done no women you
can't vote no birth control keep it
going because it's always freedom
without responsibility and so like the
remix should not no pearly said it
herself I'll tell you why though I'll
tell you why because there's freedom
without responsibility and before women
like the the like I believe in
consequences for your decision so the
men know if they vote someone batshit
crazy into Power you guys get drafted we
don't women decide elections where 55 of
the population I think if we want to
vote equally draft us y'all want
equality and personally I don't want to
get drafted so I'll be in the kitchen
okay YouTube channel she's doing good
for herself okay we did a video about
that a couple weeks back yeah yeah okay
so she's on she's on that Network I
haven't watched it so I don't know what
he's saying Abba and preach here these
guys oh my God no like should I should I
all right this is left the field by
going okay so first of all yeah this is
the elephant in there yeah this is this
is the elephant in the room because you
know what they're doing they've gone
around yeah and my man has basically
said you're misogynistic
[Music]
listen you've sat down and you've ate
off just pearly things by tagging us
yeah and your production is not our
production our production is Big out
here you get me we do we have guests
coming in we have big sets Ox blessing
you know what I'm saying we have stuff
we go we go we go outside we put people
in in black people's pockets yeah so for
two guys from wherever you look from
because it's not from Haiti because if
it was from Haiti you would have spoke
about it yeah you would have spoke about
what's going on in Haiti but don't sound
like that sound like you're from upside
so listen let me say talking to you two
guys yeah
damn he just said you're not Haitian bro
versus Man try to be like up Productions
bigger than you all right listen bro
listen bro I don't know if you just took
this out of the fresher Playbook We Like
We Are Better Than You [ __ ] period but
we get more views than you we've been on
less than you we cut our hair more than
you [ __ ] okay we get it like we hear
it all the time all right you guys don't
like the background the floor creaks we
got a simple mic maybe we need to
upscale the apartment whatever you're
better than us do not mention just
barely things again yeah otherwise it'll
be more smoke bro I've got bad smoke for
you bro both of you I got smoke for Abba
and Peach bro preach a little bit less
but I got smoke
uh I just turned 26. all right Paul just
turned 26. you little big man yeah and
I've heard you say on your pod on your
little review thing here you sit on your
own review thing
when I was younger I used to do dinner
no no no no no no you a big man trying
to tell a good Pro we've got smoke for
you look bro but bro finish your
sentences so we can actually understand
what the [ __ ] you're talking about I
gotta smoke you're not you got you're
not a problem I got smoke from you I got
smoke for you I got bread for you bro
it's not a thing and I and I can from
one there's no DJ involved why are you
scratching and rewinding my one for one
man with a speech impediment to another
bruh okay come come down and finish your
point like I don't even know what this
is about you know what you said last
video you cannot say you guys are red
pill you guys are not about massage and
you're also saying you want to remove
women's ability to vote and have access
to birth control that's it everyone go
patreon as a misogynist if you want to
be taken seriously in this public sphere
you can't say you want to take away
people's basic fundamental rights that's
it that was the entire point of the
[ __ ] video even which I think if
you're watching you probably would agree
I don't think you can really go out here
and claim you're not a racist person and
also say you want to remove black
people's ability to vote or black
people's ability to have birth control
or have premarital sex like you're just
not going to win that argument bro
please don't mention it
um when you say that don't say we just
say you got smoke because
[Music]
yeah you're a man threw you under the
bus
remember when he started this he said
just pearly things yeah
there's a bad man out here who are under
that name she's putting in money in the
pockets of Batman out here yeah they're
dead and then if you come for just party
things you come for all of us and he
went who's we he didn't throw him under
the bus well he just didn't cross
[Music]
[Laughter]
bro I got smoke I got smoke please we
got smoke bro do not come for smoke
listen if we got a thousand likes I'll
continue with more smoke for this oh you
know what they say no I don't know what
they say whether smoke there's fire
sometimes it's just smoke and I think
that's the case with this guy bear small
magnetism
[Music]
we go outside
we go inside we are going to begin the
madness Starts Now
and your production is not our
production you get me I got bad smoke
bro look at me please
you get me please
our production is Big out here you are
spreading rumors and lies rumors and
lies rumors rumors life
[Music]
yeah
bring back slavery just pearly things
women should not vote just pearly things
we've got small feet up bro
um when you say that don't say we just
say you go say we just say you look at
me
now listen if we've got a thousand likes
I'll continue with more smoke
intellectually though
again clowns
[Music]
that she came home with me cause she
knew I gotta be and I gave her this
right I'm talking about my car she did
not want this dick cause it smelled like
tar
oh it's kind of hard still we're gonna
keep going one two three if you hit
reggaeton then clap after me
hey hey actually that's why I said I got
smoke for these guys
I got smoke for them because they didn't
just say pearl they said just pearly
things they quoted it so now you're
talking about the whole network
I'ma keep it a stack bro I didn't even
know you existed before this video when
I tagged just pearly things because I
saw her debate with the feast that's it
and I said in that video bro you were in
existence that was irrelevant to me but
five minutes before this and you're
gonna be irrelevant to me five minutes
after I finish this video I'm not gonna
remember most of this I don't remember a
dude who got so in his feelings about
someone saying a fair criticism in my
opinion though that video probably
wasn't the best I can look back and say
I could have done a better job with some
of those arguments I could also say the
criticism was fair and your response to
this is you got smoke like what bro
you're gonna start an Internet beef
that's corny brother and then you're
gonna try to tell this man he's not
Haitian or he's not black and then
you're gonna try to start beef with us
like you're gonna fight people like this
is corny I don't know what it is with
black men but whenever they got issues
on these platforms it turns very quickly
they're like oh I'll box you [ __ ] or
I'll fight you I'll catch you like what
is this nonsense why y'all talking about
other people's families why are you guys
just talking about you're going You're
gonna start some beef with somebody it's
corny be a [ __ ] grown-up just get to
the point instead of saying how much
smoke you got just show us you got smoke
with some intellectual points make your
[ __ ] argument instead you hear
talking about I got smoke for these I
got smoke okay we get it bro there's a
fire somewhere move on you know what low
key after all this take off and offset
and this Migos business and all this
other stuff I'm Loki I'm tired of seeing
black men just fighting over nothing
like like people talking about like real
violence or like real for what maybe you
don't feel this way I don't know I feel
as though black dudes online constantly
have to overcompensate for their
masculinity and have to pretend they're
way tougher than they actually are just
to feel comfortable online and I'll also
say this I feel like they only have this
kind of energy for other black men
or black women but they don't talk to
people from other groups this way and
it's cringe
um I think you're right
and we had that discussion uh before and
it was not really a discussion it was
really just a comment and I understand
exactly what the [ __ ] he was talking
about
because we did a video at some point and
then it was like
it was
six months after the
fresh and fit tobacco thing yeah right
and then I was still referencing the
fight because I was still pissed off
right
and we did that video and I mentioned it
and you still you just turned to me and
you looked at me and you said like you
still on this [ __ ]
man that's I don't remember if you
remember that [ __ ] I do yeah I I edit
that out I know you did okay I know you
did yeah I remember I said that but you
like you still on this [ __ ] man man
that's corny
and I kind of understood exactly and I
got kind of self-reflected of what it is
and then I have to go back to me and why
I was so pissed and so livid
and I it made me question myself you
understand what I'm saying okay talk
about this whole thing and it made me
question about
what happened and how I could and all
that and stuff like that and what you're
talking about right there
what we're talking about we have to
always move like
weird weird we gotta assert our
masculinity and stuff like that
it's a bit about
remember the beginning of uh the the
opening monologue of uh the movie Baby
Boy Yes you remember that's it when he's
talking about how the black man's been a
baby yeah when we talk about our house
we talk about a crib yeah
we infantilizing everything so we often
have to show that we are that that
monologue that monologue is really stay
with me I didn't really comprehend with
it and and later on I kind of understood
it and then like more the depth of it
and that's really what it is a society
has done that to us which is uh really
brought us to the point of a baby and
stuff like that and the only thing
that we kind of have to do and we scream
is really just assert our manhood big
hack in the building you know I mean
that's that's that that's that's where
that's puff off our chest we gotta puff
up our chest we have to show that we're
man we're handling Biz and oftentimes
and then Biz the way we see it because
of course there's the hood mentality and
stuff like that
and you're like yeah we got to show this
and that and that is you have you have
to yeah so go with violence I got the
fact that you murdered someone or you
not someone else yeah we glorify that
because the fact that you murdered that
is that you took power over someone you
know what I mean and and and it's and
that's that's how it's translated and
soft and times so that time it made me
reflect and that's why I was like you
know what [ __ ] this [ __ ] yeah let me
just drop that [ __ ] let me just I'm not
even gonna [ __ ] reference that and
that's where this is from yeah so it's
immature this thing right here you see
this guy
I don't even know
if he knows what he's pissed about
but he can't put it in words and the way
he puts it in words doesn't really make
sense he knows there's that feeling
where he's pissed off and [ __ ] like that
and he wants to come at us he wants I
got bad smoke I got better smoke bro I
don't even know what that means what you
gonna do you're gonna come to Canada and
do some [ __ ] what are you gonna do I
think what he's saying and I understand
he's probably thinking like I felt like
my girl got attacked by these people
yeah and
she's my people and I don't want to see
her hurt so I want to protect her yeah
these manners did the reviews in front
of a camera and an iPhone don't don't
try it bro don't compare what Pearl does
to what you not do come on people come
on this show and they could tell their
views all day every day and no one stop
them Pearl gives them equal time to talk
so eat this goes out to even girls out
there that try to talk crap and follow
this misogynistic crap you don't know
what misogynistic means bro you're under
the misantry stuff here that's what you
look do bro I'll light up the internet
bro I'll light them up bro listen you
little spreading rumors and lies and
clipping things don't watch that girls
come on here every single day when we've
got shows on and talk Madness the most
Madness and expect not to get Clips bro
you look we get Clips if you talk
Madness bro you would if you talk
Madness you get clipped it's weird
hearing Road man lingo about [ __ ]
video editing
hey man hey man
I'm gonna make a tick tock of unique
cuz we real out here bro you think we
[ __ ] around coz no it's not a game
watch how quickly I'll be smooth on this
Adobe Premiere running through like Sony
Vegas take your [ __ ] out back to Vegas
and then finish him with that Final Cut
Pro like bro what was happening right
now why are you giving Thug energy about
[ __ ] video editing this is corny that
this is corny this man's giving Thug
energy over video editing that's not
what smoke means
your definition
of bad smoke
is editing
rub you you
ought to get clipped fun it's like relax
stop
just stop as they say in the UK uh
you're a backup dancer chill out stay at
home on Tick Tock and keep bang people
and do what you do bro go to your nine
to five and don't try to succeed at
nothing bro and die alone with your cats
and dogs no one cares do you you do you
boo boo but don't try tell us we can't
discuss it among people that want to
discuss it yeah stay off just pearly
things bro please
we got smoke for you please
right that was so left to filled bro but
no I'm glad you got it off your chest
we were talking about divorce I'm like I
don't even know where he's going not
because you were saying you were saying
things about because okay in the video
they was I'll address what they were
saying he's still going to address what
they were saying in the video they're
saying Pearl is misogynistic because she
thinks that women should not vote yeah
but she said that in tongue-in-cheek
yeah to bring up the the the the debate
which you are having
yeah and you said what's the debate that
women don't get caught up in the draft
sir just say that they get caught up in
the draft listen if she was just saying
that as a joke okay and I'm unaware
because I watched her say it in a few
different clips it didn't sound like she
was joking but if she was saying that in
jest and this was just some kind of bit
that she was doing then that saw me and
I shouldn't have taken her so seriously
but I'd seen her in forfeit
I got smoke too okay
the problem we got with the internet
there's the one percent people that's
dictate into 99 about how the English
language should be used like we don't
understand context we don't understand
nuances we don't understand debate so
when they try to to to to try to shift
the goal posts and make straw man
arguments we're not having it bro we
have debates on just barely things on
the gray area on on um King Richard's
show on on Andy Jenny's show it's not
just one little two guys sitting down in
front of a camera do not come for smoke
I'll come for you guys
intellectually though
intellectually I hope oh okay we brought
it back thankfully right back thank God
thank the Lord oh man I don't know where
that intellect don't come from because
you didn't display here but let's Carry
On Jesus even your team don't see it
here hey this was a [ __ ] you know
yeah that's like the last singer you're
like oh [ __ ] is that Nick Cannon hosted
and singing under the mask [ __ ] this is
a Twist
this is crazy I didn't know what this
guy was talking about bro bro well
[Music]
um
divorce let me get back to divorce guys
um as a matter of fact that might be a
good segue into the Super chats
okay I I did not think that was the
elephant in the room but you know thank
you
that's how you know you did a good job
when you get it like I don't know what
the [ __ ] that was but thanks thanks I
appreciate that thanks I guess all right
bro all right what what do I think about
this I have no problem with people
making their bread doing whatever the
[ __ ] they want I don't even know about
this platform I've not watched clips
from it uh if she's doing great things
good for her I see the channels blown up
get bread get money okay who cares about
this is like a nothing Burger it's fine
so you guys are watching though it's not
a beef I don't got a problem with just
pearly things we disagree on the topics
who cares let's just move past it it's
not that deep at the end of the day have
some fun go hug your family go see your
children go see your siblings go enjoy
life don't be on the internet talking
about you got smoke for people it's just
not worth it to everybody watching